So yesterday was day two of Donald Trump's second
impeachment trial, Monday, day one was a full
day of debate as to whether the Senate actually
has the jurisdiction to try a former president.
They decided, yes, we do, by a 56 to 44 votes. So
yesterday was sort of like the first real day with
eight hours going to the prosecution. We
saw all sorts of different presentations,
including presentations with
videos from the January 6th riots,
some of which will review later video that
was previously not seen, video that showed
just how close of a call it was for a lot of
members of the House and Senate avoiding these
riotous violent mobs incited by Donald Trump. And
you would think that even though most Republicans
have already prejudged this impeachment
trial, most Republicans have already decided
they're going to be voting to acquit regardless
of what's going on. You might have thought that
they'd have at least pretended to be paying
attention, pretended to be weighing the
presentations and making some kind of a decision
based on the evidence that was there. But they
had the benefit that the cameras did not show
the chamber at any time during the proceedings.
The cameras, as we saw during yesterday's
live streams and much of the media coverage,
were focused in quite tightly on the presenter,
the various House impeachment managers who had
turns to speak yesterday. And we were left to rely
on reports of members of the media in the chamber
to tell us what exactly were senators doing
during what are very long days of presentations.
And it turns out that many Republicans
were engaged in everything from drawing
doodles to sneaking in iPads, as Chuck Grassley
reportedly did, in order to be able to read
other material. Unclear exactly what it
was while the presentations were going on.
A Business Insider has a nice sort of
compilation of different reports about this,
and they say that many senators were distracting
themselves yesterday afternoon when the
Democratic impeachment managers
were laying out the case. Rand Paul,
who at many points appeared to be the only person
in the chamber not wearing a mask. He was doodling
and according to one report, drew a picture
of what appeared to be the Capitol, I guess
almost like architectural drawings of some kind,
according to reporters in the room during a long
stretch of the presentation. Rand Paul wasn't
even in the room, but at one point when the
proceedings went to a break, Rand Paul reportedly
ran back in and gave a note to Trump's attorney,
David Schoen. That's according to an ABC News
reporter named Alison Pekkanen. A Cynthia Lummis,
who's a Wyoming Republican at certain points, was
not wearing a mask as well. Manu Raju reporting
that Rand Paul wasn't even at his desk for
much of the 1:00 p.m. hour. That was a key
hour of presentations from the House impeachment
managers. NBC News was able to report that Senator
Mike Braun was sleeping during certain parts of
the presentation. This is not like they slept
through metaphorically. Mike Braun was literally
asleep during part of these presentations.
Rick Scott at one point was looking at a map
of what appeared to be Southeast Asia. Unclear
if he was catching up on the geopolitical
implications of the borders in Asia or maybe
figuring out where he wanted to go on an upcoming
trip. A Senator, Josh Hawley, who was one of the
main players in voting against the certification
of a number of different votes on January 6th,
at one point was leaning back with his feet up on
the back of a seat in front of him. Very remember
when Barack Obama put his feet up on the desk
in the Oval Office and it was a big scandal,
almost as big a scandal as when he wore
a tan suit or liked the wrong mustard.
And Republicans said, you don't put your
feet up in the in the Oval Office. Well,
Senator Josh Hawley with his feet up on
the seat in front of him in the Senate,
and he appeared to be reading documents
unrelated to the impeachment trial.
And he said he was reading trial
briefs. So this is I mean, listen,
if this were, you know, a lot of a lot of
Republicans have been making the case that there's
too much about this trial that's not happening the
way a real trial would happen in a court of law.
For example, many Republicans have taken issue
with the fact that Democratic Senator Patrick
Leahy was is not only presiding over the
impeachment trial, but will also be a juror
in that he is one of the hundred votes on the
conviction or acquittal of Donald Trump. And
Senator Patrick Leahy also is, in a sense, a
witness because he was there on January six. Now,
the witness thing would apply to every single one
of these senators since they were all there on
January six. So that seems to be neither here nor
there, but. One of the other important differences
between a, quote, real trial in a court of
law and what's going on here is that if normal
jurors were reading on iPads, sleeping, reading
documents related to other matters during a trial,
they would be removed from a case and it could
even potentially lead to a mistrial, depending
on what the circumstances were in a normal jury.
Many of the individuals would be disqualified, not
potentially because they were so-called
witnesses, but because they were part
of the alleged crime that took place.
What I mean by that is that many of the
senators that will be jurors, Ted Cruz, Josh
Holly and others were actually part of the two
month campaign of claiming that the election was
stolen by Joe Biden from Donald Trump. That led
to the January 6th riots in the first place. They
were essentially part of the conspiracy with the
defendant in this case, Donald Trump. So there's
a lot to sort through here, but I would hope
that everybody would be able to see that sent
reports of senators sleeping and senators sneaking
in iPads and say, listen, that's not right. Even
if they ultimately are going to vote to acquit,
they should be paying attention. But
unfortunately, there are lots of right wingers
defending this, saying it's a kangaroo court,
it's a sham, it's ridiculous. It's meaningless.
It shouldn't even be happening. So good for
these senators for literally sleeping through it.
It's stunning that this is what's going on.
It's stunning that these are the hundred
one hundred of the most powerful people in the
United States. And some of them are napping,
literally napping during the proceedings. We'll
see today how it continues. I don't expect Rand
Paul to change his behavior. I don't expect Chuck
Grassley to change his behavior. And we'll get
into some of the meat of what was presented
yesterday, which was truly stunning to see.